how do you promote your business when
nothing has worked out so far I got a
great question from one of my newsletter
readers name is Marco and I really feel
for Marco and this is like a lot of
entrepreneurs who write in to me since
my name is Marco I've had trouble
getting my business started i've done
everything i can think of websites
flyers business cards and word of mouth
up until now I've had zero response can
you give me some give me a solution how
to promote my business I'm in dire
straits money is basically finished
everything I do I love and I do it for
my children and my wife but I seem to
get nowhere I even started a second
business and still have the same problem
i can't find a job have no funds
available to finance my business further
I can't get a loan from the bank I bad
credit what is there for me to do I
really need your advice Marco Marco I
feel for you man it's hard and I know a
lot of entrepreneur collator what you do
and he said my business consists of a
mechanical workshop vehicle repairs
plumbing construction and my second
businesses company registrations taxes
couple of other necessities so there's a
couple things here a few Marco ok and
please pay attention to this because
this is huge this this will help save
your business and save your family and I
don't want you to continue down this
path of not being able to be successful
and make enough money to survive ok you
have a huge opportunity in front of you
and it sounds like you're really
hard-working dedicated guy ok to make
this work first one number thing number
one thing you have to remember you got
to pick one thing ok something your
passion about something you love doing
pick one thing you are all over the
place you've got a mechanical workshop
vehicle repairs plumbing construction
company registrations tax a couple of
other things that's all too much you're
not adding enough value here you got to
pick one thing love it and really put
your own stamp on it if you're doing
vehicle repairs people need somebody who
does vehicle repairs if you're doing
plumbing people need plumbers ok there
is a need for the stuff you're doing but
you're not getting the mess
doubt properly and it starts with one
thing so pick the thing you're best at
think the thing that you love doing pick
the thing where you can have the biggest
impact and focus on that okay so see
it's a vehicle repairs that's the first
thing you listen so I'm going to assume
you like that the most you have your
workshop you're helping people repair
their cut their cars what is it about
this thing that's different there's tons
of mechanic shops out there what's so
special about yours you have to have
something that you believe in pick one
word that you staying for and apply that
to your company i did a video not too
long ago about my own mechanic and he
treats everybody like family so family
is his word and he can build everything
up around family that's how it's going
to stand out what do you do what's your
one word what's so different about your
company you have to come up with that
that's your messaging I'm not Marco the
auto repair shop I'm Marco the blank
like what's that word you have to figure
that out okay to once you get that
that's got to be in all of your
messaging people need to be able to
quickly see what it is that you do and
what I would do your best approach to
get new business is start talking to
other companies find the guys your
customers are buying from before they'll
buy for you and after would buy for you
so if I'm if I need a car repair shop
Who am I going to go to before I have a
problem right maybe my dealer when we're
going to go to make a list of those
companies and start talking to them
maybe the insurance companies right make
a list of everybody who has anything to
do with car repair who are not your
direct competition those are guys you
need to talk to and when you call them
up or you email them or you go and show
up at their door you're not saying hey
I'm Marco I repair cars you pitch them
your message your powerful impactful
meaningful message that gets him excited
that gets them hooked and you don't need
to spend a lot of money doing this and I
don't want you spending any more money
on this because you don't have anything
left tighten up focus on that one
business get your message down start
talking to referral partners with that
clear powerful impactful message
and you'll start to see a change with
your business if you want right back
with your message and I'll help you
deconstruct it and I'll help you make it
more powerful because I really want to
see this thing take off for you I worry
about you and your family I want this to
work for you and I believe that it's
possible and I hope you do too believe
got me emotional for those are you
watching you like the video please give
it a thumbs up below makes you want to
do more and I want to hear you have to
think please leave a comment underneath
and i'll do a beauty reply if you have a
question for your company i love seeing
the comments come in they make my day
really every day when i see them come in
so thank you guys and I'll see you soon